[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenn es etwas gibt das den äußersten
osten asiens charakterisiert dann ist es
der machtkampf dass ich dort in jüngster
zeit zwischen verschiedenen politischen
und militärischen akteuren wie china
russland und den usa abspielt und wenn
es einfach gibt das von so vielen
geopolitischen turbulenzen
durchgeschüttelt wird wie kein anderes
dann ist ist das koreanische sei es in
der sowjet ära oder im zeitalter eines
aufstrebenden china
das koreanische volk das in der
vergangenheit gezwungen war zwischen den
flüssen chinas und den
expansionsbestrebungen das japanische
kaiserreich zu überleben ist heute in
zwei ideologisch gegensätzliche länder
geteilt die weiß von rivalisierenden
supermächten unterstützt werden und
zwischen denen ist viele spannungen und
enormes misstrauen gibt all das hat dazu
geführt dass die beiden koreas ihre
jeweiligen streitkräfte zur nationalen
priorität gemacht haben und wie wir alle
wissen verfügt nordkorea heute über
atomwaffen und relativ fortschrittliche
ballistische raketen technologie sowie
über abertausende von
artilleriegeschossen südkorea verfügt
seinerseits über eine der technologisch
am besten ausgerüsteten armeen der welt
eine sehr fortschrittliche luftwaffe und
eines der modernsten
raketenabwehrsysteme dieses planeten
doch trotz der tatsache dass beide
koreas bis an die zähne bewaffnet sein
scheint eine neue bewaffnete
konfrontation zwischen den beiden
ländern heutzutage eher unwahrscheinlich
zu sein
und im gegensatz zu anderen fällen in
denen ruhe durch diplomatische mittel
erreicht wurde ist der heutige
angespannte frieden auf der koreanischen
halbinsel fast ausschließlich das
ergebnis militärische abschreckung weder
die gipfeltreffen von jon bon jovi in
singapur noch die treffen zwischen und
kevin baumann genre und führen young
haben zu einer wesentlichen verbesserung
der lage geführt in korea ist der
diplomatische weg einfach eingefroren
wir sprechen von einem szenario in denen
die beiden hauptakteure eigentlich
insbesondere einer von ihnen nämlich
nordkorea nicht in der lage ist der
anderen seite auch nur einen hauch von
politischen und diplomatischen oder
militärischen boden zu überlassen
tatsache ist dass die usa keinen weg
gefunden haben führen young vom atom
kurs abzubringen denn nordkorea kann es
sich gar nicht leisten seine atomwaffen
aufzugeben da das überleben des regimes
selbst von ihnen abhängt trotz vieler
versuche ist es südkorea nicht gelungen
reformen im norden zu fördern die eine
aufhebung der sanktionen und eine
wirtschaftlich ist es am arbeit
ermöglichen würden welche
handlungsmöglichkeiten bleiben also
angesichts einer derart verfahrenen
situation eigentlich nur eine nämlich
militärische abschreckung das heißt
stark genug zu sein damit die andere
seite nicht einmal im entferntesten in
erwägung zieht einen bewaffneten angriff
zu unternehmen um ihre ziele zu
erreichen und wie genau das aussehen
wird werden der in diesem video genauer
unter die lupe nehmen aber in ein
diesmal werden wir nicht über die
nordkoreanische armee berichten denn
obwohl diese ja die armee eines streng
abgeschotteten landes ist oder gerade
deswegen wird über sie die viel mehr
gesprochen als über die viel weniger
bekannte südkoreanische armee und das
vollkommen zu unrecht den verschiedenen
schätzungen zufolge haben der ist in
südkorea mit keinem geringeren als der
sechs stärksten armee der welt zu tun
mächtiger als die streitkräfte
frankreichs oder grossbritanniens und
garantiert schlagkräftiger als die
deutsche bundeswehr also aufgepasst
[Musik]
der amerikanische schutzschild
der aufbau des südkoreanischen militärs
verlief fast ebenso erfolgreich und
furios wie das wirtschaftswunder im
süden des geteilten landes in nur einem
jahrzehnt hatte sich von einer eher
kümmerliche truppe zu einer der
modernsten armeen der welt entwickelt
wie du dir vorstellen kannst haben sie
das alles nicht ganz alleine zu stande
gebracht in diesem fall haben die
vereinigten staaten natürlich eine
schlüsselrolle gespielt
[Musik]
nach dem ende des korea kriegs in los
und 350 lag die verteidigung südkoreas
technisch gesehen in den händen der usa
die das kommando über ob container
hatten kurz für operational control
beim opfer handelt es sich um jenes
gremium das in kriegszeiten allem
militärische kontrolle hätte während des
krieges hatten die südkoreaner all ihre
militärischen ressourcen aufgebraucht
die erschöpfung und der mangel an
moderne ausrüstung machten es der
amerikanischen macht unmöglich sich
vollständig zurück zu ziehen was das
land unter den gegebenen umständen
ungeschützt und verwundbar gegenüber
seinen kommunistischen nachbarn china
und nordkorea gemacht hätte die anis
blieben also und bildeten die
südkoreanische armee aus tatsächlich
wurden die südkoreanische militär
strukturen zu einem großen teil nach dem
vorbild der us streitkräfte entworfenen
oder zumindest eindeutig von diesen
inspiriert und nicht nur das um
südkoreas aufrüstung zu kompensieren
haben die vereinigten staaten auch
einige ihrer wichtigsten strategischen
waffen in südkorea stationiert dazu
gehörten auch atomwaffen
[Musik]
ende der 50er jahre begann die
vereinigten staaten zahlreiche
atomsprengköpfen nach korea zu verlegen
bis mitte der sechziger jahre waren ist
bereits gut 1000 stück als jedoch
einerseits der kalte krieg abebbte und
andererseits die beziehungen zwischen
washington und peking sich weiter
verbessern wurde dieses mächtige signal
allmählich reduziert sodass 1991 keine
atomsprengköpfe mehr dauerhaft in
südkorea stationiert waren und genau
dasselbe geschah mit der stationierung
von us truppen deren anzahl schrittweise
reduziert wurde aber natürlich hat
südkorea den jahren in denen es
vollständig über den militärischen
schirm der usa standzeit seiner
militärischen fähigkeiten zu verbessern
präsident park chung hee selbst hatte
zum beispiel 1970 er jahren ein
ehrgeiziges programm namens juke
aufgelegt um die einheimische militär
industrie zu fördern aber es ging nicht
nur um die frage der quantitativen
aufrüstung wenn sie im militärischen
bereich wirklich ohne eigentlich sein
und die nationale sicherheit unabhängig
von den entscheidungen und washingtons
garantieren wollten brauchten die
südkoreaner modernste ausrüstung
schnelle interventionsmöglichkeiten oder
neue strukturen die an die anforderungen
der modernen kriegsführung angepasst
waren der abstand zu den großen armeen
der welt war gewaltig im vergleich zu
den damals modernen streitkräften der
europäischen mächte zum beispiel war die
südkoreanische armee ein bis zu abhängig
und zu einseitig aufgestellt prädikat
bedingt abwehrbereit scheinbar ein
hoffnungsloser fall der wohl nur vom
aktuellen zustand der deutschen
bundeswehr übertroffen werden könnte wie
also haben es die südkoreaner geschafft
ihre armee wie ein phönix aus der asche
auferstehen zu lassen und es mit ihrer
schlagkraft ist an die weltspitze zu
schaffen heute werden wir diese wichtige
frage beantworten zuvor müssen wir aber
noch selbst etwas für ab der
bereitschaft und sicherheit tun und zwar
mit etwas werbung für unsere sportart
der surft ist ein wirklich sicheres vpn
das wie der datenverkehr noch meter oder
verbindungsdaten mit lot und außerdem
jede menge security tools mitbringt so
stark ist aber aus vielen anderen
gründen ein ganz tolles wie pm natürlich
könnt ihr mit dessen hilfe auf websites
ist eine diese zugreifen die in dem land
in die mitte alles sei nicht verfügbar
sind ohne zensur und geo blocking ob
daheim oder im urlaub darüber hinaus
bietet ist jedoch weitere
sicherheits-features habt ihr nicht zum
beispiel auch ein mulmiges gefühl durch
die allgegenwärtigen der pop ups und
cookies mit soft bekommt ihr ein
handliches tool namens kalin web dass
sie alle bloggt und die damit
verbundenen gefahren beseitigt aber
nicht nur das mit nur einem stalker
konto könnt ihr alle eure geräte in vpn
registrieren handys notebooks und sogar
ihren smart tvs denkt wirklich alle
arten von geräten ab ihr bekommt damit
einen lückenlosen schutz so und weil wir
euch unsere tollen fans so lieb haben
waren wir nur bereit dieses sponsoring
zu übernehmen wenn euch server und auch
einen ordentlichen raab macht einräumt
und das ist uns gelungen mit hilfe des
rabattcodes politik.de bekommt ihr sage
und schreibe 83 prozent rabatt und
obendrein noch die ersten vier monate
gratis dazu den link zu diesem angebot
mit ihr in der beschreibung unter diesen
also nichts wie los besorgt euch surft
und hält damit gleichzeitig auch uns
damit wir euch weiterhin so informative
videos wie dieses liefern können so und
nun nichts wie ab auf die koreanische
halbinsel
[Musik]
ein kurswechsel
die große herausforderung der sich das
südkoreanische militär in den letzten 40
jahren gegenübersah bestand darin
sondern eher ein landgestützten
streitkraft zu einer viel ausgewogeneren
luft und see verteidigung überzugehen zu
diesem zweck wurden drei militärreform
durchgeführt eine im jahr 2005 eine
weitere im jahr 2011 und die letzte im
jahr 2017 unter dem derzeitigen
präsidenten mit diesen reformen wurde
das ziel verfolgt die armee erheblich zu
verkleinern
die aber gleichzeitig zu einer viel
schlagkräftigere streitkraft zu machen
die besser ausgerüstet und ausgebildet
ist effizienter eingesetzt werden kann
und sich aus besseren land- see- und
lufteinheiten zusammensetzt insgesamt
soll ein verhältnis von zwei zu eins zu
eins erreicht werde
[Musik]
obwohl viele dieser reformen
durchgeführt und weitgehend umgesetzt
wurde wurde die ob call nicht an die
südkoreaner übertrage oder steht
weiterhin unter der leitung der
vereinigten staaten und tatsächlich ist
die letzte drei militärreform namens
verteidigungs reform 20 und david der
führung des derzeitigen präsidenten nun
darauf ausgerichtet südkoreas
kapazitäten gegen den asymmetrischen
krieg nordkorea zu verbessern und auch
endlich im kriegsfall die übertragung
der opfer landshut korea zu erreichen
tatsache ist jedoch dass sich die
bemühungen bisher vor allem darauf
konzentriert haben die entwicklung von
drei schlüssel strategien gegen die
aktuelle nordkoreanischen bedrohung
abzuschließen das präventive sogenannte
kill cam system die koreanische luft und
raketenabwehr tmd und die carrier
management and recreation gmbh also die
massive straf und vergeltungs
maschinerie alle drei kam strategien
zielen auf abschreckung ab und das ist
etwas das die südkoreaner sehr sehr
ernst nehmen ohne weiter darauf
einzugehen will präsident nun die
militärausgaben zwischen 2017 und 2023
und 53 prozent erhöhen und damit von
einem budget von rund 30 milliarden
dollar pro jahr auf über 50 milliarden
dollar kommen was aber bedeutet all
diese drastischen maßnahmen in bezug auf
die bewaffnung nun das schauen wir uns
jetzt mal genauer
[Musik]
die kronjuwelen
wenn wir über militärische ausrüstung
sprechen können wir sagen dass südkorea
bereits über einige der besten
militärischen rüstungsgüter der welt
verfügt oder sich die beschaffung
gesichert hat und dabei geht es nicht
nur um nennen wir es mal traditionelle
ausrüstung zusätzlich zu den rund 2500
bauern 2400 platz alten fahrzeugen 5408
schützen und mehr als 150 modernen
kampfflugzeugen die das südkoreanische
kriegsschiff ausmachen müssen wir auch
fortschrittliche ausrüstung zur
raketenabwehr und ballistischen
abschreckung berücksichtigen außerdem
hat das land in den letzten jahren über
die anschaffung von kampfjets der
fünften generation verhandelt
[Musik]
wir sprechen zum beispiel über den
amerikanischen f 35 saves freitag von
dem südkorea 80 exemplare haben wird 60
von der version 21 von der version de
der senkrechtstarter variante darüber
hinaus entwickelt das koreanische luft
und raumfahrtunternehmen kann einen
kampfjet der fünften generation welche
der f-35 sehr ähnlich sieht und derzeit
kfx genannt wird dieses programm zielt
darauf ab dass die fähigkeiten dieses
flugzeug die des europäischen
eurofighters ohne des französischen
dassault rafale bei weitem übertreffen
das muss man sich mal auf der zunge
zergehen lassen das land mit knapp 52
millionen einwohnern ist drauf und dran
ein technologisches consorzio zu
schlagen und dass die creme de la creme
eines ganzen kontinents mit einer
zehnmal so großen bevölkerung darstellt
und es in den schatten zu stellen aber
haltet euch fest denn die koreanischen
ambitionen bei der luftverteidigung sind
wir anfang zu sehen geht es nicht minder
spannend zu die südkoreanische marine zu
dem programm zum bau und erwerb neuer u
boote durch das die entwicklung einer
neuen einheimischen oberklasse der 3
klasse und außerdem auch sie zerstöre
die mit dem aegis system ausgestattet
sind und leichte flugzeugträger von
denen aus sie die s 35 einsätzen kann
der planiger dieser massiven aufrüstung
zur see ein gewaltiges gegen die will
ich nicht nur gegen den kleinen
bayerischen rivalen im norden zu bilden
sondern vor allem gegen das gigantische
rotchina welches seine marine zu
vertrösten der welt ausgebaut und damit
ganz südostasien militärisch turnieren
möchte wir haben zu diesem thema bereits
ein eigenes video gemacht die sie über
den link in der beschreibung oder über
das symbol rechts oben ansehen kannst
und hast du überhaupt schon unseren
kanal abonniert damit du keines dieser
spannenden videos mehr verpasst falls
nein dann aber schnell und auch das
glöckchen nicht vergessen so können wir
weitermachen ich danke dir denn die
bedeutendsten militärischen
fortschrittes südkoreas mit dem
zweifelsohne im bereich der
raketenabwehr statt
[Musik]
südkorea hat bereits einen
raketenschutzschirm auf niedriger ebene
mit patriot raketen batterien
aufgestellt die das pacs system
bildungssystem das südkorea mit
sicherheit so pack 3 aufrüsten dort wo
es viel genauer und reaktionsfähiger für
angriffe mit kurz und
mittelstreckenraketen zu machen die pack
3 nutzen einen 2 putz feststoffraketen
antrieb der die höhe und die reichweite
erhöht um die verteidigungsfähigkeit
gegen neue bedrohungen sicherzustellen
so dass die modernen abfangraketen
voraussichtlich in der lage sein werden
um die neuartigen raketen bedrohungen
des nordens zu vereiteln beamter des
südkoreanischen
verteidigungsministeriums der anonym
bleiben möchte und nicht nur das eine
weitere hochwirksame raketenabwehrschild
ist ebenfalls im einsatz das berühmte
terminal high altitude area defense page
id aus den usa welches das land vor
inter continental und großrakete
schützen soll die ihn viel höherer höhe
fliegen mit der stationierung dieses
systems hat es wohl nicht weniger als
ein klar mit peking ausgelöst die
kommunistischen machthaber dort wurden
durch die potenz dieser raketenabwehr so
nervös dass sie die südkoreaner gar mit
handelssanktionen unter druck setzen und
davon abbringen wollte wieso aber ist
man in peking der dünnhäutig wenn kate
ist jedoch nur eine rein defensive
system ist ja entscheidend ist es dabei
denkt nicht desto trotz die südkoreaner
ließen sich nicht vom hohen wellen und
installierten das verteidigungssystem am
auffälligsten aber seien zweifellos
südkoreas autarkie bestrebungen man will
unabhängig werden einem dritten
raketenabwehrschild der dieses mal in
süd korea hergestellt wird die rede ist
von colby 2
das system nutzt die berühmte russische
ab wann technologie sg 100 aber moment
mal russische technologie in südkorea
tja die vereinigten staaten weigern sich
nämlich ihre art von technologie an
dritte zu lizensieren auch wenn sie so
wichtige verbündete sind also mussten
sich die südkoreaner die hosen wenden
die raketen für dieses system werden von
der südkoreanischen firma lg next one
entwickelt trotz der kosten von 1,2
millionen dollar pro stück soll das
südkoreanische system soll mit zwei
einer der billigsten raketenabwehr
städte der welt werden es ist sogar
geplant es in andere südostasiatische
länder zu exportieren
und obwohl es nicht die gleiche
reichweite die andere raketen ab das
system hat wohl die südkoreanischen
militärs seiner geringen kosten dazu
nutzen um ist im ganzen land einzusetzen
und so einen echten an dem die
südkoreanische version von israels eisen
gruppe zu schaffen als system über das
wir übrigens ein ganz eigenes video
gedreht haben das südkoreanische system
ist in der lage raketen in höhe von bis
zu 15 kilometern abzufangen die sich in
einem umkreis von 40 kilometern um den
standort finden
[Musik]
er ist dass südkorea auf diese weise ab
2020 voraussichtlich nicht ein nicht
zwei sondern gleich drei
raketenabwehrsysteme haben wird die das
land vor der nordkoreanischen betrug
schützen werden und trotzdem fragen sich
viele menschen ist das wirklich
ausreichend nur das ist die debatte die
in südkorea zur zeit geführt wird und
sicher ist dass es keinen konsens gibt
viele militärexperten und sogar
ehemalige südkoreanische minister sind
so weit gegangen dass sie fordern noch
weiter zu gehen und ein für alle mal
eigene atomwaffen zu entwickeln aber ist
es überhaupt sinnvoll dass südkorea
seine eigenen atomwaffen entwickelt ist
das militärische umsetzbar und vor allem
ist ist politisch und diplomatisch
möglich aufgepasst
eine nukleare lösung
ok viele von euch werden noch nie etwas
davon gehört haben aber ein
südkoreanisches atomprogramm ist weder
weit hergeholt noch etwas das nicht
schon einmal ausprobiert wurde anfang
der 1970 er jahre startete präsident
packt die trotz der tatsache dass sich
bereits us atomsprengköpfe in korea
befanden ein eigenes programm zur
entwicklung von atomwaffen das programm
blieb jedoch in der forschungsphase
stecken und obwohl angenommen wird dass
südkorea das nötige wissen für die
herstellung eigener atomwaffen erlangt
hatte wurde ein funktionierender
sprengkopf nie hergestellt oder getestet
warum also wurde das programm
eingestellt
[Musik]
nun das lag vor allem am druck der usa
die von anfang an gegen die
weiterverbreitung von atomwaffen in
korea waren es gelang ihnen schließlich
park davon abzubringen er stoppte das
programm und unterzeichnet der 1975 den
atomwaffensperrvertrag viele analysten
glauben jedoch dass südkorea eine
hintere auf folgenden jahren weiter
heimlich experimente durchführte und
heute in der lage wäre in höchstens 18
monaten eine eigene atombombe zu bauen
diese tatsache würde es de facto zu
einer nuklearmacht machen ein status den
es mit ländern wie japan teilen würde
und natürlich gab es in den letzten
jahren insbesondere nach den letzten
nordkoreanischen atomtests 2016 und 2017
zahlreiche stimmen in südkorea die eine
rückkehr zum einheimischen
atomwaffenprogramms forderten
tatsächlich würden momentan sage und
schreibe 69 prozent der südkoreaner die
entwicklung eigener atomwaffen
unterstützen außerdem sind die
nationalistischen und konservativsten
politiker südkoreas der meinung dass es
sich bei der strategischen verteidigung
nicht mehr auf die vereinigten staaten
verlassen könnten da deren außenpolitik
in den letzten jahren immer in
konsistenter dort
der ehemalige präsident dort trank zum
beispiel stieß die südkoreaner die
eigentlich seine besten verbündeten in
südostasien sein könnten ziemlich vor
den kopf trump entfacht streit um
kostenbeteiligung mit südkorea wir
verlieren viereinhalb milliarden dollar
um ein land zu verteidigen das
steinreich ist und uns wahrscheinlich
nicht besonders mag donald trump
präsident der usa john entfachte ein
diplomatischer streit mit südkorea um
das land dazu zu bringen mehr geld an
die usa so zahlen und die kosten für die
dort stationierten truppen auszugleichen
und trump hat ist tatsächlich geschafft
eine weitere milliarde dollar aus
präsident mundt herauszuholen und dafür
auch noch mit sport zu überziehen es war
einfach eine milliarde dollar aus
südkorea herauszubekommen als 114 dollar
13 aus einer mit kontrollierten wohnung
in brooklyn us präsident donald trump
damals fragten sich natürlich angesichts
der feindseligkeiten gegenüber südkorea
die usa während seiner präsidentschaft
an den tag gelegt haben viele ob
südkorea in bezug auf seine strategische
verteidigungsfähigkeit militärisch und
wirtschaftlich tatsächlich weiterhin von
den amerikanern abhängig sein sollte aus
diesem grund seien atomwaffen wieder in
die debatte zurückgekehrt obwohl
präsident nun bereits gesagt hat dass
dies während seiner präsidentschaft
nicht in frage käme nun ist allerdings
sogar ein gegner friedliche atomenergie
und wird in den kommenden
präsidentschaftswahlen von kandidaten
herausgefordert die allesamt pro atom
auftreten sie fordern einen ausbau der
kernkraft vorüber wäre ein eigenes video
gedreht haben und darüber hinaus
wenigstens ein atomwaffenprogramm bei
denen die usa ihre auf der halbinsel
stationierten streitmacht mit ihren
verbündeten teilen sollen und sie
fordern dass die entwicklung einer
kernwaffen ganz offiziell aufgenommen
wird us-präsident beiden versuchten im
rahmen des quads einem gegen china
gerichteten sicherheitsbündnis zwischen
den usa australien japan und indien über
welches wir bereits in einem früheren
video berichtet haben auch südkorea
einzubinden und es geht dabei recht
schnell voran im märz 2021 wurde bereits
eine um neuseeland südkorea und vietnam
erweiterte quad plus gruppe ins leben
gerufen was denkst du also sollte
südkorea angesichts der nordkoreanischen
bedrohung sein nukleare abschreckung
kapazität aus eigener kraft
sicherstellen
die
schließlich china nicht davor zurück
direkt druck auszuüben und nordkorea
bereits über atomwaffen und hat nicht
die absicht sie abzuschaffen warum also
sollte sich südkorea nicht nuklear
wappnen wäre es nicht sinnvoller eigene
atomwaffen zu entwickeln anstatt fast
25000 us soldaten im land zu haben was
wir beide länder hohe kosten und damit
verbundene reibereien verursacht oder
würde dies im gegenteil nur ein
diplomatisches probleme schaffen und
dann fliegt mit nordkorea anheizen
würden südkoreanische atomwaffen die
regionale sicherheitslage noch prekärer
machen und was ist mit china und dessen
absicht das industrielle rückgrat der
welt südostasien militärisch zu
dominieren wie würde sich eine neue
atommacht auf das gleichgewicht der
kräfte in der region auswirken müssten
die chinesen noch aggressiver vorgehen
um ihr gesicht zu wahren oder er den
rückwärtsgang einlegen weil sie in einer
nuklearen umzingelung eigentlich mehr zu
verlieren als zu gewinnen hätten tja
diese fragen sind wahrlich nicht einfach
zu beantworten aber so ist eben die lage
auf der koreanischen halbinsel grund
eigentlich erst ostasien im augenblick
und das wird sie wohl noch auf
unabsehbare zeit bleiben wie immer
freuen wir uns daher auf eure meinung zu
diesem thema ich hoffe also dass euch
dieses video gefallen hat falls jahre
gibt es wird ein like teilt ist mit
euren freunden und vergesst nicht dass
ab mit glöckchen um keines unserer
videos mehr zu verpassen machs gut und
bis bald
[Musik]